hello everyone I'm delighted to be with
hugo from in french finale here in warsaw
we're going to talk about it in french I know that
in my channel normally speaks
english but don't worry we
'll have subtitles it's there  the
perfect opportunity to practice a bit of
French so let's go hugo you have
a channel we're going to talk about three things
in fact I'm very interested to know
first of all how this
idea of ​​French Le Havre dinars came about then we
're going  talk about the cultural aspect
of learning a language because we are
a bar lives here in poland and then we
will talk we will I will ask some
questions about a hugo
on language learning because
it is a  French teacher and he
has experience in general
on learning languages ​​his
supporters then started very good
program so how did that start
there the idea of ​​​​coming French so in fact
I became a French teacher a
little by chance I have the impression that
it is ass  This is often the case with
language teachers I moved to
Warsaw in Poland 7 years ago
now because I
at that time his best friend was
Polish of Polish origin but he
had grown up in France we
met during  our studies and we
had the project of creating a company
in poland this project did not work at
all it fell through as they say
but i liked warsaw and i
wanted to try to stay  a little
longer so like a good Frenchman
I went to the French institute and at
first I thought I could help them
with their marketing or their
communication because that's what
I studied at university and but he
needed someone actually in
marketing however he was looking for a
native teacher for advanced conversation classes
so I was offered to give it a
try and I gave my first
conversation class and actually I loved it I
thought it was great especially because the
Polish people on the contrary  ment to French
after one of the languages
not because they have to but because
they like it they like to
learn languages ​​he likes French culture
so that for me it was a
super rewarding experience in fact to be
able to do a little  promotion of
French of French culture of
the history of France etc
that's it that's a bit how I
became a teacher is after three years me
I was learning Polish also at that
time I came across a
great podcast which  his name is rio for him just
because you know him well I can very
well with piotr that we greet this is the case
with this video czech czech the others
and
is therefore in fact I am looking for a
similar podcast for my intermediate level students
but I couldn't
find anything in French
that I could recommend to them so
I said to myself well well I'm going to create this
podcast myself and in fact that's
how in french started at the time.
applies to flip flops it  was a
pun with my last name stick here
and here so I created this podcast
a year later I created my first
short then the youtube channel and here
so today we have a podcast a
youtube channel and  two courses an
intermediate course and an advanced course
for people who are learning French
and I say we because we are a team
of 3 people so now there is
also a grid of anna who are part
of the team so here is a little  the history
of french dinars awesome you can
find the information in the
description by the box two said in
the box in the description in the
description it's easy in the
description so we are here in warsaw
and I wanted to ask you precisely
questions about the
cultural aspects of say
living abroad have you had
culture shocks I'm at the moment because you'd like it for
seven years recipe
have you had any
difficulties in moving  swimming have you
had culture shocks in general and
tell us a little about the experiences
you have had in poland, positive and
negative, so in fact for me the most
shocking thing was the absence of culture shocks
in the sense that  in fact during my
studies i lived a year in london too
and i feel like i had more
culture shock in london than then in
warsaw and in my opinion it was because
at the time i  I was only with
French people so we had a house where we
shared with French people
there was no English there was
no British among us so we were
a little it was more difficult in fact of
everything  arrange the formalities at the beginning the
bank account the rent and its galleys
and a little on the other hand in Poland as
I had my best Polish friend he
took care of a lot of things so
it was quite easy but afterwards at
the cultural level I  I have the impression that
when we are in europe in any case
finally  there are quite a few
differences or it's on details for
example for the French
meal times it's very important we eat at
their fixed I think it's a bit the
case for the Italians too so we have  breakfast
7:38 a.m. lunch took a
real break and dinner while the
Polish it's a bit more
run down you could say they eat when
they're hungry so they have more meals
but that's  small meals yes you
eat a sandwich for example we are
joking that there is
breakfast the second breakfast the
third breakfast and after around
6 p.m. dinner and for a French dinner at
6 p.m. it is very  strange, for example,
they tell us it's 7 or 8 p.m. so there
are small differences like that on
the organization but ultimately I have
the impression that when you're in Europe
it's quite easy to adapt to local life
if you  is a bit open-minded
obviously and then I think there's
more  differences between social groups
in quotation marks than between
countries so for example you are Italian
but as we do a bit the same thing
we have this experience on the internet and
it is finally we understand each other very
easily very well French  also so
it's easier but you see I
may have more in common with
you than with some French people who do
totally different things it's
easier for us to understand each other
than yeah it's true excellent  it's
true and I totally agree with
you on 2g breakfast for me
it's very important to have
fixed times but I saw that so it
's not the case here it's a  little
different it depends on the people
so ok well so you didn't have too much
show culture appeared too much
difficulty adapted for example
with electricity with stuff
administering formalities name on the
stage it's quite simple there is  maybe
something but that's more with my
girlfriend  e and
I don't know if it's just the
couple dynamic if it's something
cultural but sometimes we have
conversations and when my point of view
is different from hers
she tends to take it a bit
like an attack in  fact whereas
we French people it's true that we love to
debate and discuss with someone and
not to agree for us it's
almost a pleasure in fact so when we
have dinners which is good it  is
here debating exchanging
ideas trying to convince the other person
whereas with my girlfriend is in general
with the Poles that I met
I have the impression that it is rather an
exchange of  experience so everyone tells
a little about what they did but it's less
here is this debate of ideas and it's true that
sometimes salah gas my girlfriend in fact that
I want to question everything to
debate systematically it's  something
and that it's normal I don't know if you
noticed that I noticed that in France
I remember that in France
my ex-girlfriend's family are debating it and all the
time my imac and all for
hours I remind you of brunch on
Sundays at 11 o'clock after we were talking about
keeping everything we discuss and we discuss
and it was for me it was  not a
boy but it's normal that when you have
a debate sometimes there are different points
of view and sometimes people get
annoyed so but in France no I
remember discussed a bit of everything but
sometimes we got into each other  looked a little but
it was not serious well yes you are right
it's the Italians are not like that it
depends it depends on the people it depends on
the cultural johnny's nest it asks him a
lot of things in general we
love to eat we love  spend time
around the table but I think when
mostly that and you said that you were debating
with your girlfriend in which language
it's actually me the dynamics
in fact the problem is that I
met my girlfriend quite early so  it
was only six months that
i was in poland do  nc my level of Polish
was really very very very basic
which is why we started
with English is now seven years
later we still speak English together
for several reasons because
now I have a level of Polish
which  allows me to understand more or
less everything that is said to me but I
still have a little trouble with this especially
in this kind of debate for example
I would have that I will be clearly
disadvantaged because of my level of
Polish it  It's always true
that English puts us on a bit of an
equal footing, let's say, so we haven't
changed, we've tried a little to change
this dynamic, but here, for example,
after a day's work, we  is already
tired mons and excuses that I
find myself but we are tired and you see the
last thing that I want is to
make more efforts to see there
by the Polish while the English good
well now it's  is for me it's a
bit like speaking French his request
no particular effort but in general
as you have in poland and at the meeting
since these times you will surely have the
possibility of talking about
what you are doing for example when
you have I don't know at the crossroads close to
the  ugly stuff and that you will speak
Polish that you speak English there are
words you speak English because you do
n't feel too confident that under these blows
how does it actually work so for all
what daily activities
are  systematically Polish because
that's it with these interactions there
I have a lot of experience I saw
almost all the scenarios all the words
that I did not know they have already been
said to me so I had the time to
looking for them so for that I have no
problem but it's rather or when I
'm with my girlfriend's family for
example we speak Polish too
but if we're with Polish friends and
I know that he often speaks good English
in fact I am going to ask to
pass in English by  what else i
'm going as i'm quite a
shy person actually basically for me that's
a perfect excuse the
language barrier not to say anything about the evening
is so actually i prefer to ask
people to  switch to English and that
allows me to take part in the conversation
and make jokes and it's more
that if we stay in Polish or there, well,
I'm going to participate less, it's going to be
a little more, a little more disabling for
me, but  after a few glasses of wine in
general I go back to Polish so
because that the you found yourself
in annoying situations looks are
in the noble sense you feel you are
blocked you feel you block blocked
because
I think that  it's not just
situations sometimes there are also people
with whom you I don't know you don't
want to talk to before because you have
the impression that you don't feel good
around them I don't know if  you had
this impression in poland not
because i think that  the Poles
overall are very easy are
always very happy when a
foreigner takes Polish it's not like
the French or if a foreigner speaks
perfect French that's for us we
consider it normal
here as soon as a foreigner has to say a
few  words in Polish was
immediately a feat and the people encouraging us
they are really very very nice so
no I didn't have I think it's
really because I sometimes receive
emails from some of my students who  have a
hard time with the French and who
say that the French are not
patient are not nice with who
corrects them all the time etc. but in fact
often I have the impression that the
problem comes more from ourselves than from
our attitude  in fact only that of
our interlocutors so I know that
most of the blockages that I have in
relation to the Poles stop in relation
to me in fact it is not in relation
to people or my environment I
wanted  s say exactly that sometimes
it feels like it is and it
is people know it is circumstance but in
reality many people are blocked
because they themselves it was a sabotage
it is a self-sabotage
everyone is going
to watch me everyone is going to watch what
I'm saying you're going everyone it's
not necessarily like that ok very well
so we talked about shame you  live
since it's trying munn yonhap
had culture shock ideas
and experiences
i also wanted to notice that
i love poland did not
advertise poland to come to
poland but i assure you that here here
it's really great we talked we
had time to
talk about all that but like him like
hugo precisely she also said the
Polish people are very nice in
general me I had positive experiences
afterwards it depends but in
general it's me  pay but a
beautiful country and we are going to talk about the language
we  is going to talk about the Polish language
now its second part of
the interview and not just about the
Polish language general
foreign language learning
so we start with Polish but
then we will look at it earlier
may in general what is it  the
difficulties that you have for
psychological or
linguistic Polish let's say
the linguistic difficulties
I would say that well it's Polish is
part of a language group so the
Slavic languages ​​are completely different
from the Latin languages ​​compared to Spanish
for example for  a French it's
much more difficult to learn
Polish for very basic things
but the vocabulary
90% of the words that see me at the start you
really can't guess the meaning
they have so
unlike English good English  we are also
much more exposed to the language it's
easier but there are really words
we see help everywhere and here are eleven
deaths za the continuation we have no  idea of
how to read it how to pronounce it and
really you can't guess the meaning
so there is a certain it takes
some time to have a vocabulary that
already allows veil began to
understand very very basic sentences
in fact
would not  -what the word to say hello
is chuck it's not so easy already
when you see it written and pronounced
etc it's not it's not like to and in
English or even saluting French it's
here it is c  It's healthier that there was already
this vocabulary part which was quite
complicated after the grammar also
because the Polish grammar so it's
more so it works with cases of the
declensions whereas we in France and
in the Latin languages ​​of the  articles
in in Polish they have
declensions so that for me it was a
completely new system I never
learned German at school either
so here it is I maintain it I did not
learn Latin either so here it is  I
had no experience  e with the
declensions and the fact that the words
change ending according to
their functions in the sentence and that's
it for me it was
something quite complicated especially since so I
took Polish lessons at the start  and
the teachers insist a lot on this
aspect so at the beginning here we have to
learn the different cases and
we make a lot of mistakes in fact and
even the Poles make a lot
of mistakes on that which I manage to
notice now from time to time
I  am quite proud but I would say that we
have really built up having a
sufficient vocabulary to be able to
begin to understand a little
very basic things and then grammar
with this story of declensions for
me it was things the grandson I
don't know c  was the same for you
but for me it's the same but
it must be said that when I started to
learn Polish I had already
learned Russian at the top and it is
huge and I think if you know  nnais the
system is from the Slavic number after you
can apply it around Islam
but at the beginning when I learned Russian
was it was difficult because I
had and cuba I had done the from Latin
with so  it was but in general it
must be said that this is the most
problematic aspect it is precisely your
cameras and also the variations and
talk to my grandmother about it because you
were saying
how  you learned grammar in the end
so you were in school and
how do you advise learning
vacancies but in general the grandmother of
French other languages ​​how
did you learn the common strategies
of the schools to which  you make
kids that we call in English wayne
barnes in my suitcases and exercises in
front of the same time or that I do the
natural method you hear a lot you
read a lot and afterwards
so in fact when I started
Polish I had  a really
very academic approach to  at first I had a manual
where I started to do a
little exercise myself and then I took
I started working with a teacher
I had private lessons
and she precisely she insisted a
lot on on  these cases so I did
quite a lot of exercise which
helped me but then along the way so
after two years I discovered this
eight fillies podcast and there I changed
my approach a bit because  'through this
podcast I discovered the method
of natural acquisition we don't want
quotes
and from that moment I
completely stopped the
grammar exercises and I only
focused on the input so listen to a
maximum of  podcasts read a lot of
things but i think having
this theoretical base sama it helped me a
lot actually for i do
n't know if i had started directly and
only by the input maybe it
would have been  the slower my progress would have been,
it would have taken me
longer to  succeed in understanding the meaning and
that's where I saw the end of a word and
suddenly it lost me as I knew the
rule I managed to understand its role
in the sentence and that's so I
think it's  good to mix the two but
me as a teacher
promotes the input a lot that's
why in my podcast for example
there is no grammar in my videos
on youtube I try to  do as
little grammar as possible not because I
think grammar is useless but
because in my opinion for too
long we have focused only
on grammar and there are
whole generations who do not seem
to have or who  have had language lessons
for years that they are
unable to speak blank because they
did not have enough of a beam me I
take the other extreme to try to
rebalance things a little so
here I concentrate  much more about
creating interesting and
accessible content so that the  s people and
simply want to spend as much
time as possible with the language excellent I
agree but I agree with you
even if it must be said that it also depends on
this approach but we could
talk about it for hours  men
I would like to say that
precisely he did he noticed the
fact that as an adult if we
know a little explicitly the
grammar here also helps to understand
because if you start for example
spoke to
listen  and to read texts in a
survey very very far from yours
it is complicated to understand an example
the site I am sure that
if you started learning Italian
here today by reading dense texts
from  quite simple texts of course
you wouldn't have too much of course you would
need a little grammar but not too much
but rap will be different
Japanese August Korean will be
different it also depends on the distance
between the languages ​​but in general I
know  I agree with you there are a lot
of exhibitions said I hope the bridge that
exhibition expo I pass an anglicism
and after a little grammar it's
important but it must be maybe
10% 20% and it depends on the  timing is
very important speaking of grammar
important to da close to how to
learn languages ​​in general and you are
your teachers of the year so what are the
difficulties that people have
foreigners in general when it comes
to  to learn French in particular
so I have mainly experience
with Polish and
English-speaking students so I had a lot
of American British
Australian Canadian students so already it should be
noted that it is not the same
difficulties in  depending on your mother
tongue and that a lot of the
mistakes people make are related to their
mother tongue because they
tend to translate things
literally in their head it's
often a source of errors but for
example articles  it's
something very complicated in French yet
it's one of the first things you
learn from the level at one of the
first lessons it's here are the
definite articles indefinite the the hall
is one of but it's something
that we continue to learn in fact
all along because it counts it continues
to be a source of error and that if we
do not live in the country also we are
not really exposed for years
to the language  you can learn all
the grammar rules in the world to
master the articles there will
always be wee hours and i
know even for english
yet it's a simpler system
with the articles often natives
can detect someone  is not
native for example the Scandinavians who
speak very very well and who have a very
good accent but on dax little sisters
of articles they can detect that
the person but not quite attempts
so that the articles and the
pronouns  obviously  ment in ide
and so that's it it's really a
nightmare it's a bit the same thing as
the articles in fact it's really you
have to know the rules at the start to
start using them because if you don't
there is no equivalent in your language
you are not going to use them
naturally because you don't know
how it works so it is
important at the beginning to do this
in a somewhat artificial way so
to learn the rules and  to
start forcing yourself to use them but afterwards I
think it's really with the input
that you will acquire a skill that is
a little more natural I would say to
know to actually hear and
develop your ear to know
when to use a  prono or
another totally agree so you
told me to use the word calvaire this new
healthy because are you going to
meet people for whom the
French pronunciation is a calvaire
yeah a lot a lot most of the
people in fact but in  poland i
met i had several students who
had studied in roman so it's
the university in warsaw we study roman
languages ​​and they in particular
had studied french and who
spoke french better than me so it's
true it was really very
impressive who had a
really perfect pronunciation but
I had other students who spoke very
good French at the grammatical level
but who always had small
pronunciation problems
so it's true we talked a little between
us  du r so the 1st French is
really the 1d are the most
particular there are also necessarily
all the nasal sounds which
are also a little bit complex but
this r it is difficult both for
English speakers but also for
Italians Spaniards and so it's rc it's
a
big problem in learning
French g if I can't find it what I
'm going to find never watched in fact I
'm going to look for videos that teach  nt
how to pronounce the 1st french
because it is a very typical question
i would have found one in particular and if i find it i will put it in the
description mass that it was very useful
in general i think for
pronouncing words  which are which does not exist
in kindergarten you have to start from a base a
lot of blood in fact you can
reproduce it from a position of the
tongue position of the mouth that you
already know so that was the principle
of this video and if I find it
I put it in the description it's not
very elegant but less often what
I said to my students it's a bit
like you were going to spit or clear
your throat it's really there  and at the
beginning that's what I did with
my students is that I had lists
of words in the air that we read because
it's really an exercise in fact like
at the gym we repeat when  you
really want to target this thing there
you have to have a maximum of practice  ue so
I had whole lists of words
with tunes and at the beginning it's good to
force it even if they are a little
too strong so for example I don't know
what we have here a  bait a
camera force the camera and after little by
little you are going to soften it in
quotes so that it becomes more
natural to have really are rather
than having rubles camera and the r at the
beginning force yourself to act as if
you have  something in the throat and
then little by little soften it but it
helps to pronounce but often I have
the impression that people who have trouble
with pronunciation it's because
for too long they learned the
language to  the writing in fact so they
read the words in their head they
pronounce them themselves without knowing
exactly how to pronounce it and
suddenly they anchored it's pronunciation
in their mind
and afterwards it is more difficult to correct
and me by  example I think that in
Polish I have a better
pronunciation  nciation only in English which is
quite strange because very early
in learning I started to listen to a
lot of Polish instead of
concentrating only on the
written language there are a lot of words for
example I know how  pronounce them I
don't necessarily know how to write them and
on the contrary people who have trouble
with pronunciation it's because
they waited too long before being
exposed to oral language
totally agree I think that  for the
pronunciation to have there are
myths about the pronunciation it's very
difficult to pronounce a
foreign language I think that if you think
well
from the beginning after that it becomes
easier while if you ignore the
problem you lebanon I  learn the
language afterwards i'm going to learn the
pronunciation as if it were
something separate you go to a lot of a
lot more problems because the
human brain we are we are good at
sophie constitutes learns well but for
i don't know if there is a verb
like in german born in india
in english stops make
unlearn fines i don't know
if this one is so we have here
the advice the most important advice
is to start from the  beginning
and data to listen to
because it makes a huge difference
about rei we talk about music you
play you play the piano
me I started there is no I
started after I  abandoned now
you do it so I'm proud of you
it's only been two years in the
camps but still but do you
think that playing in general we're not just talking about
the piano maybe the crack of
the guitar I don't know d  other
instruments can give a
conscience it can help
in learning before because it
allows you to see how sounds work
in general when we produce sounds
because finally the language we
produce we have organs which are of
two orders  I now think  s the range
of organs that produce the language
it's like music it only hires
what you think of it then me at this
level there high phonetic level
I did not notice but on the other hand
it is in a more pragmatic way it  is
rather at the level of learning that
it helps me because I started the
piano so 2 0 and it really allows you
to put things a little in their
context and to realize how
much time it takes  to learn
anything in fact whether it's a
language the instrument if you want to learn
there's no secret that it's going to take a
lot of time and practice and the
piano voice I'm trying to do it
every day an hour a day sometimes
I'm more or less regular
but there's no secret if we do this
regularly after a while we'll
start
to acquire this skill in fact
it's really magic  because with
languages ​​it's true that the first
years we progress very  quickly and then
afterwards you have already talked about it a lot but
it is true that high level after level
b2 in fact we reach a plateau and
it is very difficult it takes a
lot of time to go to level c1
c2 we realize less
progress progress is less obvious and me
with the piano here I started 2 0
went from the stage where I don't know what
note is in front of me I can't
read a score to the stage where I am
now where I can m  sit behind
a piano I know how to name each note I
know how to play a few pieces well it
's something magical we were doing
it's super motivating so here I
understand the pl polyglots who
always want to start new
languages ​​for a bit  renewed this
feeling it's the experience so you
said precisely while polyglots
they always want to
learn other languages ​​and for you what
you want is not to learn
new languages ​​in your life because
my  now you want you speak English
fluently French of course and I speak
a little Spanish too but it was
really a very long time that I did not
practice so I understand him well but
I speak to myself very badly but it is true
that he  there's a language that has fascinated me
for years it's japanese
mainly because i love the
way it sounds
but also when i see something
written in japanese it's very mysterious
all its symbols so here i think
it  there are a lot of people who have
that I know it's going to be a
really difficult language to learn and it
won't be possible if I don't have
enough time and if I do
n't make it my priority so when the
confinement started I had  a little
more time and
but I decided to learn the piano
because I wanted to get out
of books and all that was
purely intellectual to do
something a little different so I
said to myself  here I go rather can not everything
do at the same time so
I decided to focus on the piano but
I hope one day to get into Japanese
awesome absolutely awesome thank you very much
thank you the case we could have thought we
could have talked for 2 hours to 2
hours apart from  anyway it's
been a while since we've met
less in krakow
we'll see if we make our another
video won't be the last no one of these
four anyway me I miss a
killer move to poland
where can they find so
simply if you go to an
hour french dot com you can
find the podcast the youtube channel the
courses and it is quite simply that they are there
so thank you very much go once
again and we  see you soon here on
youtube thank you luca shalom